the first stories about Harvey Weinstein
began circulating in the media about two
and a half years ago and you may
remember a famous audio clip at the time
where you could hear the movie producer
begging a young woman pleading with her
to come to his hotel room a lot young
woman was Ambra but Ilana
Gutierrez and does she is with me now
Ambra will get your reaction to today's
verdict in a moment but just to remind
our viewers what happened to you when
you encountered Harvey Weinstein at the
moment I'm super happy back in 2015 the
assault Ameen is office and I reported
everything to the police an hour after
and the next day I collaborated with
them to put a wire on me and and then
have his confession on record in unknown
records so then the situation just went
against me and I had unfortunately to
leave exiled by a new Indian from New
York tried to build up my life again but
I kept those recordings and of course in
2017 they then validated all this women
and I'm so happy for it what's your
reaction to the fact that he was only
partially convicted today not guilty on
the two most serious charges of
predatory sexual assault but found
guilty of other challenges yeah I'm
waiting for the LA case to start I'm
gonna be a witness in there and
hopefully they're gonna use those
recordings let's just remind people that
there was another trial facing Harvey
Weinstein in California two more charges
you're gonna be a witness there so I'll
be a witness in there and I hope I could
do something about because I feel that
this trial in New York was for the other
women and I'm happy for the outcome but
of course he deserved more and I'm
trying to do something about do you
think this trial really does mark a sea
change and how have law deals with cases
like this yeah I feel that at least this
is a positive outcome and it's it's like
giving the right example for people to
believe that right now there will not be
any wrongdoing two victims that you know
decided to come forward with with these
situations so I really feel this is a
start and from here we have to move
forward into not having this situation
to happen anymore and this is what I'm
working on his lawyers argued that any
sexual contact was consensual and not
only that it was transactional that
young women who wanted a career in the
movie business benefited from allowing
him to behave like this i I feel that I
can't really answer to to that for other
people but of course on my case I never
had any any sort of contact with him
after what it did to me I actually
worked the police and I never got
anything out of it and of course I feel
that right now having the support of
many other people and working together
were the other women and yeah it could
establish a very good new future to this
type of situations what would you say
about the eight women who waved their
anonymity to come into the court and
discuss the most intimate details of
their relationships in public I am very
proud of them
I really know what it means going
through traumas and opening up scars
again but they did it for helping others
and I'm really proud of them
somewhat four is what your feelings are
towards Harvey Weinstein tonight I feel
that well hey I don't know if or any
words if I think for what he did to
those women's yes and the fact that he's
now in jail that's what it's surf